hallo mein name sogar etliche kommen
heute zu einem neuen moment herzlich
willkommen zum heutigen video autocar
warum münchen im baum wie viel dezibel
hatte wohl jeder träger von max hey das
war ganz schön lässig so wie geplant auf
den weg und sie werfen den besten
content auf ganz machen hat sich eine
neue idee und zwar dieses gerät habe ich
eingestellt bei amazon gibt vor günstig
und 14 euro oder sowas macht es ganz
einfach es misst die lautstärke von
geräuschen und wir setzen heute wer von
uns unterschiedliche geräusche
laut eugen kann dafür habe ich mir einen
lauten und blumen menschen geholt
wir sind irgendwo ins nirgendwo gefahren
und es ist wirklich nicht viel um uns
herum wetter glaube ich mal können wir
richtig laut sein
ich würde sagen willinger verlost aber
wir starten mit den schreien weil das
ist immerhin das krasseste überhaupt wir
fangen einfach mal leise an und zwar mit
schnitzen dafür leute kommen her ist
einfach ein sehr lauter schnitzen kann
ich mache den anfang also alles ruhig
jetzt erstmal meinen versuch 75 watt
drei versuche jahre das life changing
konntet leute das ist das ist nicht
irgendwie reaction ja oder ja keine
ahnung wissenschaft
alter schwede kraft
das klingt einfach nicht wenn man mal
ein bisschen lauter redet dann sieht man
dass die lautstärke bei lauterer
gespräch lautstärke war schon fast am
schreien angrenzt bei über 80 dezibel
ist luca am trigger und gib mir dein
bestes ohne ein bub beim ersten versuch
hier schon gewonnen aber wenn jetzt noch
mal zweimal szene interessen vieler
stellen natürlich jahr das ja auch
anwesend
in pflege ich behaupte von mir dass ich
extrem laut klatschen kann jana heßler
bitte mal gar nichts gehört man einen
schrei gehört
[Gelächter]
73,5 44,2 alter das ist echt nicht viel
ich bin einfach der ball kommt und muss
ich kurz ein trendiger ich wette dass
ich dann erstmal mehr als 80 in kriege
gar nicht witzig frank er 75 schalter
der punkt dann ist er verehrte diana
dran heißt dass wir dort gewinnen bietet
daran strecken wert gewonnen
ich könnte es bitte einmal aussprechen
ich habe gewonnen exchange ist wir
probieren genau ein dezibel werte zu
treffen indem wir ein geräusch macht
ruhig sagt zum beispiel 80 db und das
geräusch machen
80 80
ja das machen wird und die wahl beginnt
ja nun dass seine db anzahl selbst
vorbei 73 ich sage 85 85 85,7 um 0,7 bis
ich mein ganzes leben schon 82
mit luca los wenn er normal redet ist er
so laut dass wenn ich schreibe alles
machen leute
darauf warte schon ihr ganzes leben ich
denke es wahrscheinlich ein süßes
mädchen die kann ich laut schreien aber
macht du kannst glaub's nicht mehr hat
ein machen wenn du richtig hart wie wäre
es mit hoch und laut über 100 m war
ich glaube gerade wirklich dass ein paar
leute gleich aus dem fenster gucken
werden
da spreche ich nicht wirklich leute
managerin aber es halt so kraft wieder
weil wir auf einem berg stehen
naja wie auch immer ich bringe jetzt
hinter mit 123 112,4 meine stimmbänder
sind aber nicht weste
fachleute jana war laut heldt ist was
wirklich trocken
114 nein schreibt nicht einfach alle
gegen die wand ich habe versucht durch
ryder was ging nicht ich glaube er hat
mich ja nicht an ich habe die grundtöne
big thing aber leute was ihr nicht wisst
ich war vor einer woche oder so schon
mal mit dem dinge move und habe auch die
leute aus dem u vor allem kräftig
rheinstein lassen darunter auch regie
und ihr werde man sehen man denkt ja
immer diverse genau machst du sehr gut
man denkt ja immer reverso der lauteste
mensch auf der welt aber ob das stimm-
und wer insgesamt am lautesten geschrien
hat seht ihr jetzt quelle für fashion
konnte wie carter 23 und sebastian hat
115 basler der seychellen monat 12 13
dann kannst du das geschafft was dem
moment was aktuell darf der 108
was mir jetzt einen tiefen schreiben nur
ein klein also sebastian ist insgesamt
der gewinner wenn ich mein part 2 volt
mit anderen geräuschen schreibt die
kommentare was wir noch damit machen
können
was hat euch gefallen
[Musik]
auf unserer gruppe auf den weg
deshalb glaube ich mal können wir
richtig laut sein wie start mit den
schreien weil das ist immer in der kasse
überhaupt gefahren werden enden damit
ihr alle bitten meine dran bleibt warum
ich denn jetzt bekommen wir fangen
einfach mal leider an und war mit
schnitzen
also alles ruhig jetzt war die
gelegenheit nicht betreffen drei gehört
[Musik]
machen
also eine tatsächliche gewinner ist
sebastian [ __ ]
thomas hat euch gefallen ich habe mich
echt bemüht irgendwie was aufzunehmen
was ich so noch nie gesehen habe hier
ist ein kanal abonniert knopf hier
abonnieren altes video nein gewiss kein
altes video und damaskus bis zunächst 1